aquí tenemos una simulación creada por
un usuario de khan academy llamado
justine gates que sirve para ayudarnos a
comprender el porqué dividir entre n
menos 1 nos da un estimado in sesgado de
la varianza de la población cuando
tratamos de calcular la varianza de la
muestra esta población tiene una
distribución plana de probabilidad de 0
a 200 luego comenzamos a muestrear a la
población y vamos a usar muestras de
tamaño de 50 y lo que vamos a hacer es
que para cada una de esas muestras
calculamos la varianza con base en la
división entre n luego entre n menos 1 y
luego entre n menos 2 conforme seguimos
generando más muestras y calculamos la
media de cada una de las variantes que
calculamos de manera diferente veremos
hacia donde convergen esas medias aquí
hay una muestra aquí hay otra muestra si
hago clic puedo agregar muestras
continuamente y vemos que ocurre algo
interesante cuando dividimos entre n
tenemos que la varianza de la muestra
a pesar de calcular la media de
muchísimas varianzas de la muestra se
sigue subestimando la varianza real
cuando dividimos entre n menos 1 veo que
obtengo un muy buen estimado la media de
las varianzas converge hacia la varianza
real cuando divido entre n menos 2 está
muy claro que sobre estimamos la media
de la varianza de las muestras con
respecto a la varianza real esto nos da
una muy buena visión del por que lo
mejor es dividir entre n menos 1
aquí tenemos otra forma interesante de
visualizarlo en este eje horizontal
comparamos cada gráfica de nuestras
muestras y mientras se encuentren más a
la derecha significa que tanto sobrepasa
la media de la media verdadera y
mientras más a la izquierda significa
que tanto está por debajo de la media
verdadera si vemos la muestra que está
hasta la extrema derecha es la media de
la muestra que sobrepasa más su valor al
de la media verdadera
muestra que está más a la izquierda es
la media de la muestra que está más por
debajo de la media verdadera y está de
en medio está un poquitito por arriba de
la media en el eje vertical cuando
usamos n como denominador calculamos dos
varianzas diferentes con una varianza
usamos la media de la muestra y con la
otra varianza usamos la media de la
población y en el eje vertical
comparamos la diferencia entre la media
que calculamos usando la media de la
muestra y la media que calculamos con la
media de la población por ejemplo este
punto de aquí abajo a la izquierda
cuando calculamos la media con la media
de la muestra que es lo que hacemos
normalmente subestimamos
significativamente lo que hubiera sido
la media si supiéramos cuál es la media
de la población y la hubiéramos
calculado de esa manera así obtenemos
esta forma interesante sobre la cual nos
recomiendan reflexionar por qué se da
esta forma y qué significa
otra cosa interesante es que cuando la
vemos de esta forma es muy claro que
toda esta gráfica se encuentra por
debajo del eje horizontal por lo que
siempre que calculamos la varianza de la
muestra
usando esta forma cuando usamos la media
de la muestra que es lo que siempre
hacemos siempre obtendremos una varianza
menor que la varianza que obtenemos al
usar la media de la población en cambio
aquí cuando dividimos entre n menos 1 no
siempre la subestimamos a veces la sobra
estimamos y al tomar la media de todas
estas varianzas convencemos hacia la
verdadera y aquí abajo la sobre
estimamos con mayor frecuencia y para
dejar claro a qué nos referimos con
estas gráficas copiamos la pantalla para
verla con mayor detalle en esta gráfica
esta distancia vertical significa que
cada una de estas muestras se calcularon
usando la varianza de la muestra usando
la media de la muestra y en este caso
usamos n en nuestro denominador
es este caso de aquí y a este le
restamos una pseudo varianza de la
muestra que tendríamos si de alguna
forma conociéramos la media de la
población esto no es algo que veamos con
frecuencia en estadística pero es una
medida de que tanto subestimamos nuestra
varianza de la muestra dado que no
tenemos la media verdadera de la
población a nuestra disposición
esto es esta distancia y pueden ver que
siempre estamos subestimando aquí abajo
sobre estimamos un poco y también
subestimamos pero cuando tomamos la
media o las promediamos todas convergen
hacia el valor real
aquí dividimos entre n menos uno y aquí
abajo dividimos entre n menos 2